- A lot of people have
their own different niche,
and you know, you don't have to be
a super lyricist or a storyteller.
It could just be the energy you bring.
People don't like to look
themselves in the mirror.
That's the hardest thing to do, you know,
is to critique yourself.
When I started doing music,
at first I was selfish.
Doing music, I mean, that I like.
You want the flashy
things until, you know,
you grow older, you know, as an adult.
And you be able to understand
yourself a little bit more.
- He's an American rapper
from Compton, California.
His major label debut
was in October of 2012,
to critical success.
Time named him one of the hundred
most influential people
in the world in 2016.
He's Kendrick Lamar and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success.
As you guys watch and listen,
if you hear something that Kendrick says
that you really love,
make sure to leave it
in the comments below with quotation marks
so we can keep track of what impacted you.
(logo swooshing)
- It's a whole world out there, man,
that believes in what you
can do and what you can say
and the energy you bring, you know.
I'm not even just justifying myself.
A lot of people have
their own different niche,
and you know, you don't have to be
a super lyricist or a storyteller.
It could just be the energy you bring.
Know what I'm saying,
they believe in that.
But the moment they feel like
you don't believe in that no more
and you just going with the next trend,
whether it's 808s or whether
it's a up-tempo or slow-tempo--
- [Man] Autotune or whatever.
- Exactly.
They don't believe in
you no more, you know,
the culture don't believe in you no more.
So stand behind what you do and you know,
the world is going to move by it.
And that's exactly how I look at it.
People don't like to look
at themselves in the mirror.
That's the hardest thing to do, you know,
is to critique yourself
rather than point the finger.
Everybody hates change.
So to actually do that and say
"I'm wrong in a lot of areas."
I look at myself in the
mirror and I'm saying,
"I'm wrong in a lot of areas,"
that takes a lot of willpower,
you dig what I'm saying?
So it started with self first.
The nickname, that been
acquired since I was a kid,
just being in the neighborhood.
Something given to me by just my homeboys
growing up in Compton, so that
name will always be there.
I'll go back to the city now
and they don't call me Kendrick.
I just felt like it was
a time for me to grow,
you know, not only as a
artist but as a person.
I want the world to know me for who I am.
And I just sit back and
reflect on why Tupac
is one of the greatest,
why BIG's one of the greatest, why Jay is.
Because the people felt
like they had a connection,
it wasn't just a facade that
you seen on stage or on TV.
People actually felt like it was a part
of what you was going through
and your worries and just life in general.
You know, I said what
better way to start that
rather than giving them my real name,
letting them know who I am as a person.
My songs are personal, I do
try to make it universal.
It took me a long time to figure that out,
and not stay just in that one box.
Because now I know the world is listening.
When I started doing music,
at first I was selfish.
Doing music, I mean, that I like.
I got a whole community behind me now,
you know what I'm saying?
So it's more of a responsibility
'cause they banking on me
to have some positive light.
You know what I mean, the city of Compton,
there's always been a
negative stigma there.
So I'm at a point now
where I can walk through any neighborhood
and they'll be like, "Yo
nigga, you better go.
You better do it for us
because at the end of the day,
we going to be locked up."
They're locked up in the
penitentiary calling me and saying,
"Yo, I need you to look
out for my little son
or my nephew through your
music," dig what I'm saying?
That's a responsibility I have
and that's what keeps me humble, man.
That and just life in
general, and my family.
I'm the oldest of four, you know,
so I got to make a for them
and make a positive life for them.
My little brother's 17 now and
he's in the city of Compton.
He might go through the same
steps and mistakes that I made.
So that's what really humbles
me and keeps my head level.
I think some of my best
advice recently came from Dre,
is to keep the passion for the music.
You know, always keep that
because so many people lose passion
and everything's starting
to be about a dollar
and that's when you know the
value of the music goes down.
When I was listening to NWA,
anything that I did in the streets,
it wasn't from NWA, it was because
my cousins was doing it,
you know, my uncle was.
A song really didn't,
the songs that they had
was just autobiography
of what I seen anyway.
So for me, personally, knowing
how kids react to music,
that's why I tend to always
have the reasoning behind it.
It's still gangsta rap, it's still harsh.
And some parents may not want their kids
to listen to some records.
Not all records, but some records.
But at the same time, when
I do do these records,
it's a sort of responsibility of giving,
like I said, the happenings behind it.
Yeah, you can go kill somebody,
I'm going to talk about killing somebody,
but I'm not going to talk
about it without saying
that you're risking your
life for 25 years times four
in the state correctional facility.
It's not just doing it for fun,
with bottles and women around me.
I'm talking about it
with cuffs and chains,
you know what I'm saying?
Any kid that's listening to it,
you're going to have a precaution.
That's the realities that be.
I'm just going to continue to give people
what I know, what I want to know,
what they don't know, and
what we all can learn.
The reason why we're on earth
today, you, me, him, her,
all these different walks of life,
is all a test, it's
almost like an experiment,
God's experiment.
When are we going to understand
that we are put on earth to love?
That's all it's about.
Everybody wants to figure
out how complicated
life is and break it down.
This is what I truly think.
I really think that
it's going to keep going on.
War going to keep going on,
frustration going to keep going
on, anger will keep going on,
'til we finally go back
down to the simplest word.
Love.
And when God sees that,
then we have an answer.
But until then it's going to be warfare.
You want the flashy
things until, you know,
you grow older, you know, as an adult.
And you be able to understand
yourself a little bit more.
I learned that them things
didn't make me happy.
I learned that money really don't make me,
I'm learning that now, you know.
That's not really my peace
of mind, having money.
That's something I learned this
year and years before that.
And learned that jewelry
and all that stuff
won't really make me happy.
And when you learn that,
you'll be able to grow,
grow more as a person.
What makes me happy is
really challenging myself
and knowing that I defeated my last goal
and took myself to the next
level, was a better person.
- It was for real, I think.
They called you "The Black Dylan."
- That was crazy.
- Yeah, 'cause Dylan was prolific,
and I'm sure that's
where he's coming from.
- Yeah, definitely.
Always said, man, if I'm going to do this
I'm going to say something.
I'm not just going to
rap a bunch of verses.
(audience applauding, cheering)
That's what Dylan, you
know, he's a legend.
And he said something,
he voiced his opinion.
And the world gravitated towards it
and I want to do that with music.
- [Reporter] This young, dedicated artist
can't help but reflect on
those who once doubted him.
- [Kendrick] They never said
I wasn't talented enough.
They'll say something like,
"The industry is shady.
You don't need to be doing this."
I respect their opinions
but at the end of the day
I have to follow my heart
and that's what I want to do.
It was a passion, I couldn't shake it.
And I be hurt now if
I didn't stick with it
because it'll always be on my head.
(logo swooshing)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
The King Slayer asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Kendrick's top ten rules
had the biggest impact on you and why,
what change you're going to make
in your business after
watching this video.
And if you like some of the quotes
that other people have
shared from Kendrick
down below in the quotations,
give it a thumbs-up to show your approval.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout-out
to Jason "J-Ryze Fonceca
from ryzeonline.com,
friend of the channel who picked up
another copy of the book.
J-Ryze, really appreciate the love.
For those of you guys watching,
if you want your chance at a shout-out
in a future video, make sure
to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(logo swooshing)
- Make sure you're dedicated, you know.
'Cause doing it half-assed
ain't going to get you nowhere.
And if it do get you somewhere,
you ain't going to be there too long.
You got to make sure you're
rally dedicated to the music
- One of my teachers, he actually said,
"The day you stop being scared
to touch people and talk to people,
that's the day your mind will
open up to so many things."
I try to imply what I learned
in 7th grade even to this day.
- Challenge.
Other rappers.
Have you been hearing things
coming out of other rappers
that are going back at
you, or is it dying down?
Or do they just take it as a challenge?
- Yeah, I think they just
take it as a challenge.
But you know, the whole point of the thing
is not just to challenge for the moment.
Challlenge for the whole
extension of this hip-hop culture,
not just off the hype, but
what we going to do after,
what we going to do to challenge ourself,
how we going to make better records,
how we going to push forward
and innovate the next generation coming up
rather than just sticking
in the moment of a verse.
So that was the whole point of the joint
and I hope everybody really
get the ideal behind it.